>> Jeanine: SOCIALIST
BERNIE SANDERS FINALLY BREAKING
HIS SILENCE ON CUBA.
AND OF COURSE HE'S TAKING A SHOT
AT AMERICA.
BERNIE GOING SOFT ON THE
COMMUNIST REGIME WHEN PRESSED ON
IT.
>> DURING THE CAMPAIGN YOU SAID
THAT IT'S UNFAIR TO SIMPLY SAY
EVERYTHING IS BAD IN CUBA.
DO YOU STILL SHARE THAT
SENTIMENT NOW THAT THE PEOPLE
THERE SEEM TO BE --
>> I SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
LATIN AMERICA AND IN CUBA AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE, THE RIGHT OF
PEOPLE TO PROTEST FOR A DECENT
ECONOMY AND FOR POLITICAL
FREEDOM.
>> Jeanine: AND BERNIE'S
RESPONSE WOULDN'T BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT BLAMING AMERICA.
INSTEAD OF DECADES OF A
COMMUNIST DICTATORSHIP.
HE TWEETED THIS.
QUOTE, "IT'S ALSO LONG PAST TIME
TO END THE EMBARGO ON CUBA,
WHICH HAS ONLY HURT AND NOT HELP
THE CUBAN PEOPLE."
I WILL GO TO YOU, GREG.
TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
IN CUBA WHO ARE PROTESTING
ALLEGEDLY ARE PROTESTING OVER
COVID, ACCORDING TO THE CUBAN --
WHAT IS IT?
>> Greg: SERVICES?
>> Jeanine: WHENEVER, THE
GOVERNMENT.
IS IT REALLY ABOUT COVID?
>> Greg: OF COURSE NOT.
COVID JUST BRINGS OUT THE WORST
IN A DOOMED SOCIETY.
FOR SANDERS, IT'S HARD TO
CONDEMN SOMETHING OR AN IDEA
THAT YOU'VE ALMOST PAYS FOR YOUR
ENTIRE LIFE.
IT GOES BACK TO THE ENEMY OF
INTELLECTUAL GROWTH, WHICH IS
THE SUNK COST.
IF YOU'VE INVESTED 70 YEARS OF
YOUR LIFE AND AN IDEA THAT
DESTROYS ENTITIES ONCE THEY
ADOPT IT, IT'S KIND OF HARD.
IT'S A LITTLE LATE FOR BERNIE TO
TURN THAT TRUCK AROUND.
IT'S THE IDEOLOGICAL EQUIVALENT
OF A MONEY PIT.
YOU CAN'T STOP PUTTING MONEY
INTO IT.
BERNIE DENOUNCING CUBA WOULD BE
LIKE CNN DENOUNCING FAKE NEWS.
THAT'S YOUR BRAND.
JESSE DENOUNCING HAIR GEL, DANA
DENOUNCING JASPER, ME DENOUNCING
RAW SEXUALITY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jeanine: THAT WAS A GREAT
ANSWER.
THANK YOU.
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF
AMERICA SEEM TO BE BACKING THE
CLAIM THAT THEY ARE NOT
PROTESTING ABOUT FREEDOM, BUT
THEY ARE PROTESTING ABOUT OTHER
THINGS LIKE THE ECONOMY.
>> Dana: THEN THEY SHOULD TAKE
SPANISH CLASS, BECAUSE LIBERTAD,
WHICH THEY ARE ASKING FOR, MEANS
FREEDOM, LIBERTY, WHICH IS WHAT
THEY ARE ASKING FOR.
YOU CAN SEE IT'S REALLY
GRASSROOTS IN SUCH A SLOT OF
INCLUDING A RAP ARTIST HE WAS
LIKE, "I'M GOING TO GO FORWARD,"
BECAUSE THEY ARE SICK OF IT,
THEY ARE TIRED AND WANT TO HELP.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, FOR THE
CUBANS, IT IS BIDEN AND NOT
BERNIE WHO IS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I DON'T THINK BIDEN IS EXACTLY
WHERE OBAMA WAS ON THIS.
REMEMBER, HE WENT FULL NORMALIZE
RELATIONS, AND THE EMBARGO,
DOING ALL THESE THINGS.
TRUMP WALKED IT BACK.
I DON'T THINK BIDEN WILL GO BACK
TO THE OBAMA VERSION.
ONCE, THEY SAW WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN THEY SQUASHED -- OR DIDN'T
HELP -- THE REVOLUTION IN IRAN.
AND THEY DON'T WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN THERE IN CUBA.
THE DISCOURAGING THING IS THAT
THE INTERNET HAS BEEN SHUT DOWN
AND COMMUNICATION HAS KIND OF
STOPPED THERE, SO IF THERE'S
ANYONE OUT THERE THAT HAS THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD ALLOW
THESE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER,
IT'S GOOD.
THE OTHER BAD NEWS IS APPARENTLY
A LOT OF THESE DISSIDENTS WHO
WERE JAILED ARE BEING TREATED
TERRIBLY AND THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THAT, TOO.
>> Jeanine: THAT'S TRUE, THEY
ARE BEING TREATED TERRIBLY.
WE FOUND OUT THAT THERE ARE MORE
THAN 100 MISSING OR ARRESTED,
AND ONE INCLUDED A JOURNALIST.
WHAT SHOULD WE BE DOING?
>> Jesse: WE DON'T HAVE A
GREAT TRACK RECORD OF DEALING
WITH THAT REGIME, SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO.
EVERY ATTEMPT WE'VE MADE TO
OVERTHROW THAT REGIME HAS
BACKFIRED, SO THIS MIGHT BE A
TIME TO WAIT IT OUT.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
BERNIE SANDERS HERE.
JUST A LITTLE HISTORY LESSON,
THE REASON WE HAVE THE EMBARGO
AGAINST CUBA IS BECAUSE THE
SOVIETS PUT MISSILES IN CUBA.
BALLISTIC MISSILES POINTED AT
THE UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE 90 MILES OFF THE SHORE
OF KEY WEST.
YOU THINK THAT'S OKAY?
LET'S JUST DROP THE EMBARGO AND
ALL THE ENEMIES OF AMERICA JUST
SEND MISSILES TO CUBA AND POINT
THEM AT WASHINGTON, D.C.
THAT'S WHY BERNIE SANDERS IS
DANGEROUSLY STUPID.
DOES BERNIE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
COMMUNISM WOULD WORK IF WE JUST
DROPPED THE EMBARGO?
NO, THE REGIME WILL JUST PILFER
ALL THE STUFF AND BASICALLY USE
PATRONAGE TO SET UP A PERMANENT
AND NEVER-ENDING AUTHORITARIAN
REGIME.
HERE'S WHAT BERNIE -- AND THIS
IS GREG'S POINT HERE -- HERE IS
WHAT BERNIE IS SAYING.
HE NEVER ADDRESSES THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE IN THESE COMMUNIST
COUNTRIES HATE IT.
THEY ARE SUFFERING.
HE NEVER TALKS ABOUT THAT, HE
ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT THEORETICAL
COMMUNISM AND THEORETICAL
SOCIALISM, AND THAT'S BECAUSE
HE'S ARROGANT.
AND HE BELIEVES THAT COMMUNISM
OR SOCIALISM WOULD WORK IN THIS
COUNTRY, AND PEOPLE WOULD LIKE
IT IF BERNIE SANDERS COULD
ADMINISTER IT, AND THAT'S A
FALLACY.
>> Jeanine: HE SAID IT WAS
WORKING IN VENEZUELA UNTIL IT
WASN'T, THAT HE HAD A TAKE IT
OFF THE WEBSITE.
WHAT ABOUT THE SQUAD CONNECT
THEY ARE QUIET ON THIS ONE.
>> Harold: I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
THEM, I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I HAVE NOT BEEN, PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS NOT BEEN.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
AND SAID, AND THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
YOU HAVE A DECAYING, CORRUPT
COMMUNIST REGIME 90 MILES OFF
OUR SHORE.
AT SOME LEVEL WE OUGHT TO STEP
BACK AND PONDER THAT QUESTION,
ANYBODY IN THEIR RIGHT MIND
CAN'T SUPPORT WHAT'S HAPPENING
THERE AND HAS TO BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THESE PROTESTERS.
TO JESSE'S POINT, THIS COULD BE
ONE OF THOSE TIPPING POINT
MOMENTS WHERE THE PEOPLE DECIDE
THEY WANT THIS, AND WE HAVE TO
DECIDE HOW WE WANT TO BE
HELPFUL, IF WE CUT, AND IF WE
COULD BE CONSTRUCTIVE AND
HELPFUL.
FINALLY, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ENTIRE REGION, YOU LOOK AT OUR
ENTIRE HEMISPHERE, ONE OF THE
REASONS I BELIEVE, AS MUCH AS WE
SPEND MONEY AND OTHER
HEMISPHERES AROUND THE GLOBE TO
TRY TO STABILIZE THINGS -- AND
WE SHOULD -- WE SPEND VERY
LITTLE HERE.
>> Jeanine: SO TRUE.
>> Harold: HAD TO THINK ABOUT
THAT IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
TAKE BERNIE AND THE SQUAD OUT OF
THAT AND THINK ABOUT IT FROM A
FOREIGN POLICY AND NATIONAL
SECURITY STANDPOINT.
>> Jeanine: THAT'S A GREAT
POINT, IT REALLY IS.